4e match nul de la saison pour
versailles ce samedi 10 novembre les
versailles et n'ont pas réussi à forcer
le verrou défensif des ulis lors de
cette 9e journée de national 3 score
final 0 à 0 malgré une nette domination
des joueurs de la cité royale a bien
maîtrisé le jeu on a eu beaucoup
d'action le problème c'est qu'on manque
d'efficacité pour la maîtrise du jeu on
était là les postes sont bas les actions
c'est le sentiment d'avoir fait le
maximum pour pouvoir forcer la décision
en notre faveur mais mais il nous a
manqué un petit peu ce brin de réussite
ce dernier geste qui nous aurait permis
d'ouvrir le score je pense de gagner ce
match s'il attaque reste perfectible la
défense de versailles rassure l'équipe
n'a encaissé que cinq buts en huit
matches disputés cette saison l'arrivée
de charlie temps je sais tu étais n'y
est peut-être pas étrangère le gardien
de but de 36 ans a notamment joué en
première division a lancé à liverpool et
en équipe nationale avec le cameroun
charlie temps chez un professionnel un
professionnel une belle carrière une
belle carte de visite des clubs
prestigieux
coupe du monde donc c'est ça reste ça
reste quelqu'un dans le monde du
football et c'est vraiment une chance de
l'avoir parmi nous au quotidien ce qu'il
apporte par ses qualités de joueur de
footballeur mais aussi par ses qualités
humaines
donc c'est un exemple à suivre pour tous
nos joueurs ils sont un vrai plus il
faudra un charles itandje de gala
jusqu'à la fin de la saison pour
atteindre les objectifs du club
terminer dans le top 5 du championnat et
pourquoi pas réaliser un parcours
historique en coupe de france et
versailles et seront opposés ce dimanche
le 18 novembre à l'ess dragon un club
polynésie au 7e tour de la compétition